18 months ago i spoke at the davos forum
and i
emphasized once again that the unipolar
world order era was over
and i would like to
take this issue up once again because
it's still relevant despite all the
attempts to
preserve the old world order you know
it's only the natural course of history
change is the natural course of history
because civilizational diversity of the
planet and the richness of cultures can
hardly be reconciled with political
economic and other ready-made templates
templates won't
fly there
us declared a victory in the cold war
and later came to think of themselves as
god's own messengers on planet earth who
have no duties only interests
and the latter are declared as sacred
sanct
it's as if they choose to ignore that
over the recent decade the planet has
seen the emergence and increasing
prominence of new powerful centers each
and every
center is developing its own political
systems social institutions implementing
their own economic growth models and
certainly they have the right to protect
them and to ensure their national
sovereignty
it would be
a mistake to think that during these
tumultuous changes you can simply sit it
out
bidding your time that everything is
going to get back to circuits that
everything is going to be as it was it
won't
and yet it seems as if the ruling elites
of certain western countries are
laboring under precisely these very
illusions choosing to ignore the obvious
persistently cleaning to the ghosts of
the past in particular they think that
the domination of the western global
politics and economics is a constant but
nothing is preemptory nothing is eternal
they think that the rest of the world is
periphery their own backyard
and they still treat those
countries as their colonies and people
who live there well they are considered
to be second grade because they think of
themselves as
exclusive as
something first-rate and that's why they
have this irrepressible
desire to economically crush those who
break the mode who refuses to blindly
follow they rudely and brazenly obtude
their ethics cultural and historical
views sometimes calling to question this
sovereignty and integrity of countries
and threaten their own existence suffice
it to remember what happened to
yugoslavia syria
iraq and if they fail to keep these
rebels so to speak in
czech they try to isolate them and a
council they use everything sport the
olympic movement bans on culture and art
masterpieces due to this so reason that
their authors have their own origins and
this is the nature of the current bout
of russophobia in the west as well as
the reckless sanctions against russia
i would say reckless and insane
sanctions
the number
and the rate at which these sanctions
are rubber stamped well it's
unprecedented i understand the russian
now they tried to and
crush russian economy in one go by fools
disrupting business
chains
making western companies leave the
russian market freezing our
assets dealing a blow to the industry to
finance to the level of
life of our people but it didn't work
the russian
enterprises this and the government
authorities worked in a composed and
professional manner the citizens
stand united and they assume
responsibility we're normalizing the
economic situation we stabilize the
financial markets the banking system the
trade system and we injected liquidity
and working capital into the economy to
ensure the sustainability of enterprises
and companies employment and jobs the
gloomy predictions with regard to the
prospect of the russian economy that we
had in the beginning of spring didn't
realize they understand where this
propaganda campaign comes from where
these mantras about the dollar at 200
rubles and the inevitable and rapid
collapse of our economy this is
a tool of information warfare
a factor of psychological influence on
our society and in our business circles
incidentally some of our experts fell
victim to this external pressure and
their
calculation and estimates they assumed
that
our gdp would inevitably plummet and
robot would depreciate critically but
the
life itself proved wrong these
predictions but i would like to
emphasize that in order to be successful
we need to be frank and realistic in our
assessment of the situation we have to
be
independent and draw in our conclusions
and
be believe in ourselves whereas strong
nations strong people and we are up to
any challenge and as our forefathers we
can find a solution to any task and this
is proved by the thousand years of
history of russia
three months after the full-blown
package of sanctions we suppressed the
inflation
surge it peaked at 17.8 percent right
now it's gone down to 16.7
and continues to decrease the economic
dynamics has been stabilized the public
finance is stable
i'm going to draw a parallel with other
regions later
yes of course it's too much 16.7 percent
percent of inflation is a big number and
we will have to address that and i'm
confident that we will be successful
over the first five months this year the
federal budget has a surplus of 1.5
trillion rubles whereas the consolidated
budget has a
a surplus of 3.3 trillion rubles
incidentally and may alone the surplus
of the federal budget stood at
500 billion rubles which is four
times what we saw
last year in maine right now we need to
boost production
boost the supply in the domestic market
and based on the growth of supply we
have to
rebuild and demand and bank
banking lending
i said that we've taken measures to top
up the working capital of capitals
almost in all
areas business has the right to get
deferrals and insurance payments over
the second quarter this year
manufacturing capacities have greater
opportunities they can resort to this
deferral in the third quarter too after
a drastic surge in spring interest rates
in the russian economy are steadily
going down the central bank has brought
down the key rate and that is why i
believe that we can once again bring
down the concessional mortgage rate down
to seven percent this time
distinguished colleagues as i mentioned
previously the economic bleed squeak
from russia was doomed from the
very outset
incidentally as is well known
and as we know from practice of recent
years sanctions are a double-edged sword
they can deal
comparable if not greater damage to the
authors and developers of these ideas
and i'm not just talking about
short-term
fallout
we know
from leaders of european countries from
informal talks
they are discreetly discussing alarming
prospects they believe that sanctions
can be applied not just from russia but
from any country that falls out of favor
sooner or later they can be used against
the very members of the eu and european
companies so far it has not come to this
but the european economies have already
dealt
a serious blow to their own economies
and they did it themselves
we see
an aggravation of social and economic
issues in europe and in the us we see
increases and the prices of goods food
electricity as well as car fuel
the standards of leaving of europeans
are going down their enterprises are
losing competitiveness experts estimate
that the direct
estimatable losses of the eu from the
sanctions fever over this year can be
superior to 500 billion dollars these is
the price of these
decisions divorced from reality and
taken in contribution contravention of
common sense right now the most
important task for us is to boost these
supplies of food to the global market
satisfying the needs of countries that
are
needed most directly russia is
satisfying its own domestic needs but it
is still capable of significantly
increasing the exports of food and
fertilizers next season our grain
exports can rise to
50 million tons
will prioritize supplies to those
countries
that
need food most where there are risks
that the number of starving people will
increase i referring particular to the
african countries and to the middle east
at the same time there are problems and
once again we're not the blame for those
difficulties yes officially russian
grain food and fertilizers incidentally
the u.s
imposed sanctions on fertilizers then
the europeans
followed the suit
then the u.s simply cancelled these
sanctions but the europeans didn't
because you know their bureaucracy is
working like the millstone
at the mill
of the 17th century they understand that
that's silly but they cannot
backtrack due to bureaucratic concerns
reiterate russia stands willing to make
its own contribution to rebalancing the
world agricultural markets
and we take note that our
colleagues from the u.n are open
to engage in a dialect on this issue
because they understand the acuteness of
the global food problem
we could talk in the course of this
discussion about creating normal
conditions from the point of view of
logistics finance and transport to boost
russian exports of food and fertilize
fertilizers unfortunately there are many
speculations about other matter about
ukrainian suppliers of food to the world
markets we're not preventing these
supplies because we were not the ones to
plant mines around their black sea ports
they can de-mine that and we will ensure
the security of these vessels
no doubt about that
but
the us department of agriculture
estimate that it's six million tons of
weed we believe it's five million
another seven
ton of
corn
but
you know 800 million tons of wheat is
produced across the world so 5 million
as a drop in the bucket moreover there
are opportunities to export
that you can do that through the black
sea pools through belarus through poland
through romania there are
paths there are
five or six routes that can be used so
we are not the ones to blame
it's about how reasonable the people
sitting in kieva it's up to them to
decide
and they shouldn't listen to their
foreign
masters
from the other side of the ocean